[Music]
okay stars born we kind of put this on
off for a long time I kind of have low
expectations of it I didn't really want
to see it but I would characterize this
one as a romantic tragedy set in the
world of music entertainment of course
lots of good cameos unexpected cameos
from people that you won't expect you
know and lots of good acting good
singing I'd say overall I like the movie
I like the movie I did too I like was
not really liked but you know we were
kind of like putting it out in the plane
for Silla actually yeah it was pretty
good movie acting was good a story was
good singing was fantastic what I liked
about the movies that they actually play
an entire numbers yeah so you could hear
the whole song
[Music]
yeah it's essentially a chick flick it
is I'm just gonna come out and say that
but uh guys can it's tolerable because
it has a good male lead in it too so
very good very good very much natural
yeah actor it's super believable one of
the one of the better movies that we've
seen in recent times I'm not gonna okay
if I'm gonna put it on a level of
Bohemian Rhapsody but it's very
different it's a lot longer Bohemian
Rhapsody was just like a [ __ ] fun
fest to the whole thing you know it was
a feel-good movie this is a tragedy this
one is less fun yes but still good still
good still good to see a lot of good
songs I mean anybody that has seen it I
mean this movie has been made many times
like adapted for different time periods
so most people know how the story goes
it is a try very tragic story yeah
tragic love story and kind of rags to
riches type of thing and you know like I
said they just adapt it for whatever
time period they make it but actually I
think they did a really good job on that
songs were good like the cinematography
was really cool at big moments yeah like
the lead and the two leads a really good
really good chemistry with one another
yeah and I'm not gonna spoil it with
that audience but that scene at the
Grammys yeah yeah yeah I was just
cringing yeah excellent date movie next
day movies yeah but we go this will go
ahead hit up but other than that there's
really nothing we can say about in terms
of spoilers or anything it was very
unexpected it's it's I really
underestimated underestimated the movie
but yeah it was good yeah it's very
liked it a lot actually
right
mmm okay so we're back at it again and
we just got done seeing it was Deadpool
once upon a Deadpool now he saw the very
first Deadpool last night we rented it
and it was a good movie I thought it was
entertaining and I would probably say
that I'd say this one was as
entertaining as yeah I think this is
maybe a little bit funnier like it
started out but a little less funny but
then it got like funnier is it leather
yeah and I'm really sure whether or not
this is the third movie or the second I
think it's the third well I did the
first one yeah but uh it was good they
kind of they tweaked it to be pg-13 but
they did it in a way to barely skirt the
rules and they made fun of it you know
the movie kind of makes fun of itself a
lot and it makes fun of superhero movies
which is awesome because the six buckets
suck but it was it was it wasn't like
I'd recommend it you know it was it was
entertaining I liked I liked that they
did the wraparound story cuz like I said
it's very funny that pretty much all the
jokes and like references they make it
matter like people our age yeah yeah
like even they made like say anything
all the musical humor Princess Bride
yeah very next generation yeah so so
much of the references are Hades
references yeah but it was like it was
really funny it was kind of like a you
know I'm assembling well I happen to
assemble a supergroup and can't spoil it
it's just it's it's really funny it's
really I think it's a little bit funnier
than the first one it's very similar
oh yeah the similar tone like I think
for a while like at the beginning I was
like oh this is kind of funny
it's the first one but then it got
funnier the only downsides to this
series so far that I've noticed is that
he gets kind of annoying now it's
supposed to get annoying but he never
shuts up and it's just constant dumb
jokes some of them better than the other
once it can get kind of on your nerves
for a while but then the movie even says
that he gets on your nerves
oh yeah that's that's kind of the point
this is yeah yeah but you know yeah I
guess it's worth seeing I really liked
it it was funny yeah
yes gone okay we just got done seeing
one called instant family we were kind
of dredging the very bottom of the
[ __ ] barrel this is the one of the
last ones we wanted to see because the
new batch isn't out yet that starts
tomorrow but anyway I characterized this
as a family drama with a bunch of comedy
in it about a middle-aged couple who
adopt an entire family of you of
siblings you know it was a teenage girl
and boy and a girl other than that well
I'm gonna let Jenny handle that again I
wasn't really the intended audience for
this what did you think of this about
what I expected it's kind of like and I
think I said this to you on the way here
I'm like I'm sure it's gonna be fine it
is a you know it's got heartwarming
moments it has funny moments Manji bad
cringy family so it's it's pretty much
goes the way you expected a little bit
funnier than I was expecting a couple of
the jokes were a little bit darker than
yeah it's expecting which I kind of
liked they played a Bauhaus song in it
yeah I was gonna say it was like yeah
there was like one part where I'm not
gonna say what it is yeah this janitor
he's like I'm an ex gen soundtrack yeah
it did I liked Mark Wahlberg in it he
was actually kind of funny he was you
know it was a good shape it's funny
because I think the reason that he works
in these kind of movies he has that and
you saw this in Boogie Nights I played
dark Dirk Diggler where he's just like
this kind of like yeah yeah he's like
affable likeable he's like kind of an
idiot but like he's used to love him
anyway and
you know he's kind of like naive in a
way that's kind of charming
I guess yeah so but I kind of liked I
don't know it's like I said it's about
what you expect you know kind of a
family moment theater was filled with
x-gen and above single women mostly yeah
I'm the guy in there and a couple of
those anyway he was kind of in and out
okay a lot of the same movies because on
the a-list you see just getting out of
the house yeah it's like if you like
this kind of thing like kind of
heartwarming it was kind of like
something you would see on Hallmark
Channel yeah it's a very life time yeah
although I must say that it did directly
cater to its market I mean the women
were loved we're loving it they were
eating it up I was to me I was like this
is sappy it is a bit sappy not as snappy
as I was expecting but it's still pretty
[ __ ] sappy yeah sure I'm not like not
a bad movie it did your liver on what it
promised I mean there are people that
want this [ __ ] it's just not me yeah
it's like I'm not gonna [ __ ] on it's
fine for you acting was good production
was good all that's just it
it was the genre that particular genre
we're not in that yes serviceable yes
[Music]